I want to begin our
discussion of computability
by taking you back to
early high school or
late middle school, when you first
learned about the notion of a function.
Here we have the teacher, and
here are some very earnest
students sitting in the front row.
The teacher begins by defining the
notion of a relation, saying that it is
a set of ordered pairs,
where the first element comes from a set
called the domain, and the second
comes from a set called the range.
And a function then is a special
kind of relation where
each element of the domain is paired
with exactly one element of the range.
And of course this rather
abstract definition
is well beyond the maturity
of everyone in the class.
Then, the teacher writes some
examples of functions on the board.
Like f(x)=3x+2, or g(x)= -x2+1.
And then the students get
a flash of insight and
say to themselves, oh I get it.
A function is what you do
to x in order to get y.
I mean f(x).
In effect, the student understands
the function as an algorithm,
a finite number of steps to follow that
let's you find the output given an input.
Notice, however, that the teacher's
definition was very different,
being given in terms of the rather
abstract notion of sets.
Now for the rest of this algebra class,
and maybe for as much math as this
student studies, the difference
between the student's computational
understanding and the teacher's
definition, won't be important.
The student will know how to
solve all the problems and
probably won't give the teacher's
definition much more thought.
In reality however there's a profound
difference between these two notions.
And indeed this difference between
computation on the one hand and
functions on the other,
will be the subject of
the first part of this course.